people beginning i think to wake up a
little bit to this obviously some people
on the right have been woke to this from
the top
but even some people on the left are
waking up to the
oligarchic tendencies
technocratic oligarchic tendencies this
tendency to take power
for a handful of elites on the left
sarah silverman
a left-wing comedienne certainly
not a conservative this lady she was
just complaining about about the
democratic party
and how elitist it's all become
it's the absolutist
ness of the party i am in
that is such a turn off to me
it's so [ __ ] elitist you know for
something called progressive
it allows for zero progress
it's all or nothing no steps toward
all or nothing so
i sympathize with her her exasperation i
guess i empathize with it too
but i don't think she's right i don't
think what she's saying is exactly i
don't think it's all or nothing i think
the way the left has
won in this country on at least on the
cultural matters
is through incremental change this is
actually the topic of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which you can pre-order now until
it's canceled and then you can't
pre-order it which is
that for at least 60-80 years
the left was gaining ground engaging in
what
a brilliant leftist theorist called a
war of position where you infiltrate the
institutions
you gain power and then slowly slowly
gradually gradually
you begin to exercise that power and
then when you've got enough leverage you
can
suddenly spring a lot of social changes
on people
this to attain what he called the
cultural hegemony
which was the big impediment to leftist
radicals upending society
i want to focus though on this elitism
thing because
creating a new elitism is the point of
progressivism she's saying it like it's
a contradiction that's so weird we're
supposed to be progressives but we're
elitist
the whole point of progressivism you can
read this in woodrow wilson's essay what
is progress
he's our first left-wing progressive
president
he said the constitutional order was
under the laws of isaac newton
fixed laws permanent laws to the
universe permanent human nature
but now we're living under the world of
darwin where everything is mutable and
changeable and evolving
and in that world the constitution is
outdated so what we need to do
is instead of being governed by the
people according to the constitution
we need a group of intellectual
progressive elites
to make all of our decisions for us and
we're going to outsource this to
something called the administrative
state
and then we're going to you know still
have politics kind of we're gonna debate
pointless stuff but really the decisions
are gonna be made by experts
such as dr fauci sarah silverman goes on
again righteousness porn
and i've been thinking about this a lot
just in general
i i just i don't know that i want to be
associated with any party
i really i think i don't want to be
associated with
any party anymore it just
it comes with too much baggage
every party it comes with so much
[ __ ] baggage that no
ideas can be taken at face value
and without ideas what are we
without a common truth how can we talk
about it
you know dante actually makes this point
in the divine comedy when he's talking
to his ancestor kacha guida
talks about becoming a party of one
because the parties are always going to
disappoint you because they're these
institutions so
there's something profound in what she's
saying and i'm glad she wants to break
away from her own party
but the thing is she's accusing
progressives of falling into this trap
of
dithering because everything's got to be
perfect and it's all or nothing and so
they don't get anything done
she's falling into the same dithering
trap because in politics if you want to
do anything
you need to operate in tandem with other
people
and the way that we do that is we form
associations that we call political
parties
and that's how you build a consensus and
get things accomplished
you need political parties to do stuff
in government such as ours
even further though even for this whole
both parties are terrible thing i'm so
i'm too good for all these parties
to me this whole shtick is so arrogant
and presumptuous
statistically 100 of voters fall
into one of the two major political
parties you're talking now about 150
million people
in this last election depending on the
numbers you're looking at it could be
160 million people fall into these two
parties those are just the voters
even more than that identify with the
parties
if all those people are in one of the
two parties and you're not
is it possible that you're the one with
the problem
it can't possibly be you right it's got
to be 150 million people totally wrong
me totally right generally speaking the
reason people fall into these parties
the reason the parties form
is because there's some coherence to the
ideas the idea that i would protect
life and protect my property the idea
that i would you know protect life
through social policy and protect my
property through economic policy
those things go together they come from
a coherent
uh base that forms a political vision
that then expresses itself in various
policies
same thing on the left the idea that you
would upend various social policies
end up end the economic institutions of
government end up end our foreign policy
sure it comes from the same broad
political vision
and maybe you have a problem with that
but i think it's so arrogant to say
and now whatever heterodox views i hold
that's my real opinion
no maybe you're just beginning to
question your old political vision
but you haven't taken the time and the
effort to
follow your new curiosities to their
logical conclusion
which might not leave you alone outside
the political system it just might
flip you over to the other side
some guys are able to evade political
categorization
guys like bill maher now bill maher he's
a left-winger he's a democrat
but more than most left-wingers and
democrats he sort of
contradicts his own group every now and
again and it's won some respect
from right-wingers usually i disagree
with bill maher but occasionally i agree
with him and he's made this point
getting back all the way to what we were
talking about at the top with that
military guy prattling on about how
women or
pregnant women are just as lethal as men
he says americans are
becoming a silly people
and finally new rule you're not going to
win the battle for the 21st century if
you are
a silly people and americans are a silly
people
that's the classic phrase from lawrence
of arabia when lawrence tells his
bedouin allies that as long as they stay
a bunch of squabbling tribes
they will remain a silly people well
we're the silly people now
do you know who doesn't care that
there's a stereotype of a chinese man in
a dr
seuss book china all 1.4 billion of them
could give a crouching tiger flying
[Applause]
because they're not a silly people if
anything they are as serious as a prison
fight
look we all know china does bad stuff
they break promises about hong kong
autonomy they put uyghurs in camps and
punish dissent and we don't want to be
that but
it's got to be something between
authoritarian government that tells
everyone what to do
and a representative government that
can't do anything at
all thank you bill he's ninety percent
right here ten percent he's confused but
ninety percent right
thank you first of all this
dichotomy he's making between
authoritarian government
and free representative government i
think it's kind of a false dichotomy
because america has always been a
representative government i think we're
less representative now
than we used to be during the founding
era now we have government
largely by administrative fiat not by
the will of the people
as we as we vote but
do you think that america in 2021 is
more or less authoritarian than we were
in 1790 i
i think a lot of people would say that
we are
less authoritarian right we can
say more things we have less strict
social mores just just on the
example of free speech
we can now burn the american flag
while downloading high-speed porn
probably in public in some places
while smoking a fat blunt and
nobody will say boo about it
all of those various activities are in
in various ways protected by the law
you couldn't have done that in 1790 so
then you'd say okay well that's
it was more authoritarian way back then
but in some ways it's much more
authoritarian now
because we can vote and we can vote and
we can vote
and if our votes if our expressed will
either that of the people or of our
representatives contradicts
the politically correct bureaucratically
entrenched orthodoxy it's not going to
go anywhere
that's why these things often die in the
courts that's why
that's why president trump you elect
president trump but he can't even
control the executive branch in many
ways because the bureaucracy
functions on its own according to
progressivism as it was established 100
years ago
that is some
useless i think sort of a dichotomy
question is do we have purpose do we not
have purpose
in the 1790s i think we had purpose as a
country i think we had a shared
sense of national identity and i think
we understood
our purpose as a country our ideals how
we were going to put them into practice
now i don't think we do this is a sign
of decadent cultures
and we i think have certainly fallen
into decadence
decadent and decay describe the same
sort of things
so what we do is we turn inward this is
expressed in declining birth rates we're
not really as focused on the next
generation
this is expressed in exploding debt
we're not focused on the next generation
right we're just focused on spending
spending spending
and ourselves having a luxurious sort of
lifestyle we're focused on our own
appetites so much of our national debate
revolves around which of our sexual
desires we're allowed to pursue
today and and which new desires we'll be
able to pursue
tomorrow we're not talking about broader
things we're not talking about virtue
all that much we're not talking about
our international our geopolitical ends
we're not talking about higher ideals
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
you